So the answer to the problem, as you may
have found out is 5. But there are
actually two different ways that you can
solve this problem. Let's go through both
of them. So, if you remember our order of
operations acronym, PEMDADS> This tells us
that, before we do any subtraction, which
we'll have to do right here. We need to
deal with whatever's happening inside
parentheses. So if we were following this
set of rules, we would say that this is
equal to 10 minus dealing with what's
inside the parentheses, 2+3 is 5, and then
we would do the subtraction, 10-5 is 5.
However, as we saw in dealing with the
equation that we gave to Grant, there's a
way to get rid of parentheses, so that we
can solve this problem in different way.
Let's pretend that the numbers that we
have up here actually refer to some
objects. Let's say these circles that I
have done here right now. So, here are ten
circles and I want to figure how to modify
these super circles in accordance with
this expression. So we have ten vice, and
then you want to get rid of 2+3 of them.
So if we did the problem the original way,
where we have 10-5 circles. Then we would
just count out five of these 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, select just those ones and then get rid
of them. And then in the end we're left
with 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, five circles. However,
let's talk about how to do the problem in
the other way. Instead of grouping the
circles that we want to get rid of as one
whole group, as we did in the first way,
so that's by dealing with what's inside
the parenthesis first, and circling all
five of the circles we want to get rid of,
let's think about these as two separate
groups. So, we know that we want to get
rid of two circles. So that's just these
two and we also want to get rid of three
circles. Now instead of merging these into
one group like we did the first way, why
don't we just get rid of each of them
separately since we know that we need to
get rid of this whole thing. So first
we'll get rid of these two and then we'll
get rid of these three as well and in the
end we' re left with the same five circles
that were when we did the problem the
first way. So what we really did was
subtract two circles. So 10 minus 2
circles and then we subtracted the 3. So
this gave us, our final five circles.